[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
ein sehr stark angefragt das rezept
nämlich nudeln mit einer leckeren käse
sahne soße
[Musik]
diese nudeln sind besonders bei kindern
sehr beliebt aber auch erwachsene
erfreuen sich ab und zu an den genuss
von einer leckeren käse sahne soße
wir benötigen nudeln ich habe hier
spiral modeln genommen außerdem gouda
und nimmt da bitte den frischen und
treibt ihn am besten selber genauso wie
sein parmesan außerdem milch sahne
butter mehl etwas gemüsebrühe und ein
bisschen muskatnuss vorbei mit der sauce
anfang geben wir zuallererst in
kochendes salzwasser unsere nudeln
in einem anderen topf oder in einer
anderen pfanne geben wir dann die butter
hinein und lassen sie bei mittlerer
stufe schmelzen
danach kommt in einem schwung das mehl
hinzu und wird gut untergerührt so
erhalten wir eine mehlschwitze und
sobald ihr merkt dass du das mehl so ein
wenig anfängt zu blubbern oder blasen zu
bilden dann ist es genau richtig
nun geben wird ganz langsam immer
schluck für schluck die milch mit hinzu
macht das am besten wie ich in seinen
ganz dünnen strahl und dann habt ihr
wirklich die garantie dass ich keine
klumpen bilden
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann die milch komplett
eingearbeitet hat gibt die sahne mit
hinzu
an der stelle würzen wir das ganze auch
schon mit der gemüsebrühe und der
muskatnuss salz wird in der regel nicht
benötigt denn der käse ist ja schon seit
ich genug
nun wird das ganze einmal auf gekocht
und anschließend geben wir den käse mit
dazu
[Musik]
meine zwei lieblings käsesorten für
diese soße sind gouda käse und parmesan
ihr könnt natürlich den käse nehmen der
euch am liebsten gefällt
an der stelle könnte den herd auch schon
ausschalten und sobald die gewünschte
seligkeit erreicht ist ist eure käse so
es auch schon fertig für mich ist es
perfekt wenn sie noch ein wenig flüssig
ist und wenn die nudeln auch gar sind
können wir sie einmal abgießen und mit
zu käse sahne sauce geben
dann wird das ganze einmal gut
untergerührt und ihr könnt euch die
warme käse sahne sauce mit euren nudeln
schmecken lassen
als ihr das ganze aber jetzt nochmal mit
käse überbacken möchte dann tut das
gerne einfach die nudeln in eine
auflaufform legen käse darüber geben und
so lange bei 81 grad backen bis der käse
geschmolzen ist
[Musik]
wenn wir das ganze jetzt noch mit
paprika flocken und wenn ihr die nudeln
nachmachen möchte dann schaut gerne mal
unten in der infobox da stehen alle
zutaten mit den genauen mengenangaben
und ich freue mich wenn ihr in einer
woche zu meinem nächsten nudel rezept
auch wieder einschaltet bis zum nächsten
mal auf welches kitchen
[Musik]